bonjour à tous nous allons commencer par
une petite expérience je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux
quelques instants imaginez vous essayez
de vous représenter un paysage parce que
je vous dis voyage à cheval
à quoi est ce que vous pensez
probablement un superbe cheval un
paysage splendide et un coucher de
soleil et un coucher de soleil comme on
en voit rarement bien vous pouvez ouvrir
les yeux alors j'imagine ça ressemble à
peu près à quelque chose comme ça c'est
pas mal il y a maintenant bientôt trois
ans à septembre 2016 morgan
tout juste diplômé d'un diplôme
d'infirmière charles en école de
commerce et moi-même en études de
physique fondamentale nous lancions
après une année de préparation dans un
projet plutôt ambitieux qui était de
partir traverser l'amérique latine à
cheval nous avions la folle ambition de
franchir traverser la cordillère des
andes à travers le pérou puis
l'altiplano bolivien où qui est une
sorte de plateau juché à plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude avant de poursuivre en
argentine
jusque une région jusqu'à jusqu'à
rejoindre une région qui se nomme la
patagonie
nous avons fait ce voyage nous avons
nous avons réussi nous sommes partis de
lima après avoir acheté cinq chevaux
dans des sites eu dans une situation
rocambolesque
puis tous les trois nous avons franchi
pérou et bolivie
lorsque au sud de la bolivie morgan est
rentré en france tel que c'était prévu
nous avons poursuivi avec charles au
nord de l'argentine jusqu'à rejoindre la
ville de même de sa mère de sa qui était
le terme du voyage de charles
qui rentre à son tour en france et me là
sa seule pour terminer de traverser en
patagonie
alors là c'est le moment où vous dites
oh là là mais c'est trop stylé comme
projet nord est et moi j'ai les
chevilles qui enflent et je vous dis
ouais carrément carrément c'est
carrément stylet et d'ailleurs je vais
vous montrer des photos pour montrer à
quel point cet accord plus stylé ce que
vous pensez qu est ce que vous pensez
alors voilà ça c'est nous 3-2 face sa sé
nou 3-2 d'eau
sa sé nou 3 en train de nous prendre
pour des cow boys ça c'est moi ça c'est
pour faire le malin sur facebook ça et
ça c'était lorsque j'étais lorsque
j'étais seul en patagonie bien ça va
bien 20 secondes m'enfin faut pas
exagérer moi lorsqu'on me pose la
question de sa lorsque me pose la
question du voyage à cheval
la première impression qui me vient
c'est plutôt quelque chose comme ça et
si je devais définir le voyage à cheval
je dirais que c'est une succession de
catastrophes pendant un an alors
catastrophe en quel sens je vais vous
donner un exemple et vous allez très
vite comprendre cela fait plusieurs
semaines que nous sommes partis de lima
et nous avons déjà beaucoup de retard
sur nos prévisions nous décidons donc de
d'affréter un camion pour rejoindre une
petite ville de mai ou en kabylie qu'à
200 km plus au sud
d'où la traversée de la cordillère
pourra véritablement commencé nous
arrivons après une journée de deux
camions justement est sur place il est
21h il fait nuit noire
nous ne savons pas où aller et des
barques qui la police alors il faut
savoir que la police au pérou c'est
l'une des institutions les plus
corrompues du pays et deuxième point
important à savoir c'était que nous vous
n'avez pas de papiers bref la soirée
commençait plutôt bien mais à vrai dire
ça ça c'est pas très grave
ce qui était gênant c'est est que au
delà de ça charles et moi en riant la
tête comme un ballon après un match de
foot à cause du manque d'eau à cause du
manque d'oxygène et de l'attitude parce
que nous sommes à plus de 4000 mètres
d'altitude
morgane elle est directement passé au
niveau 2 du mal des montagnes
puisqu'elle ne tient même plus debout
pas son temps à vomir et j à moitié
agonisante dans la rue à côté de nos
affaires ça la rigueur ça va mais mais
le problème c'est que au moment à ce
moment là nous sommes aussi obligés de
gérer une une bande de chiens errants
qui lorgne sur nos chevaux et quelques
badauds un peu trop curieux qui
s'intéressent à nos affaires et au delà
de ça nous cherchons un lieu où dormir
et un peu de fourrage pour nos chevaux
malheureusement en arrivant en amérique
latine aucun de nous trois ne parle
espagnol et c'est donc avec quelques
soucis que nous avons tenté ovale à 2
par l'espagnol
bref alors lorsqu il ne s'agissait pas
de de cheval volet perdu eliard est
embourbé dans quelques marécages de
traversée de 2,1 gle de pseudo raccourci
qui termine en stage survie lorsqu'ils
ne s'agissait pas de passer des chevaux
en contrebande de nuit à la frontière
entre deux pays
lorsqu'il ne s'agissait pas de
villageois qui voulaient nous faire la
peau
nous avons fait l'expérience très
concrète d'un concept que vous
connaissez tous l'enfer c'est les
coéquipiers
au delà du fait que oui en l'occurrence
mes coéquipiers tpe plutôt unanimes pour
dire que leur faire c'était moi mais bon
plus sérieusement au delà du fait qu'ils
avaient probablement peut-être même très
largement raison voyage et 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 avec ses coéquipiers
condamnés à supporter les odeurs
insupportables défaut et ce dans la dans
la poussière dans la dans le froid dans
la faim dans le dans l'ordre dans la
crasse
bref c'est à devenir dingue
alors vous me dire pourquoi être parti
en voyage pour pour cette succession de
catastrophes
eh bien je vais vous je vous donnais un
jeu vous raconter une petite histoire
au crépuscule de sa vie un vieil homme
s'était retiré dans sa maison dans une
belle demeure à l'écart du monde où il
passe l'essentiel de ses journées de ses
nuits dans cette bibliothèque
par une belle journée d'été il convoqua
à l'un de ses arrière petits fils à son
bureau et celui ci se rendit bien que
très fortement impressionné il se rendit
à la convocation
le jeune garçon partager le même amour
des livres que son arrière-grand-père et
ce fut donc émerveillé qu'il vit son
grand-père se levait aller doucement un
rayonnage et de l'étagère tiré un livre
immense est pesant il lui dit emporte le
je te le donne à l'enfant l'enfant pris
le livre et tenta de déchiffrer le titre
il était écrit lass lass des bois scouts
alors en réalité c'était des cris las
des boy scouts mais c'est une bille en
anglais et il s'agissait de l'histoire
de quelques jeunes gens partis au début
du 20e siècle
faire le tour du monde et qui avait vécu
d
des aventures toutes plus
extraordinaires toutes plus irréalistes
les unes que les autres il s'agissait
bien sûr d'un roman mais d'un roman
parfaitement démodé que plus personne ne
lisez plus depuis des années l'enfant
pourtant je suis passionné par ce livre
et en conserve a pieusement le souvenir
en grandissant
cet enfant voulait peut-être deviné
c'était moi j'ai grandi
plongez dans le récit d'antiques épopée
de chevalier errant quête d' aventure
invariablement accueillis à la tombée du
jour
tels des princes dont quelques châteaux
perdu aux confins de forêt enchantée
j'ai grandi à l'ombre des exploits des
héros les anciens jours à 6 h il
ulysse hector il va nouer le prince eric
la duchesse de berry et de tous ces
récits où des héros réels ou imaginaires
vivait penney lutter ou mouret avec une
grandeur d'âme et un courage à laquelle
nous ne sommes plus guère habitués c'est
ainsi que jeune garçon puis étudiant à
paris
je ne suis jamais parvenu à m'habituer à
ce monde où où les usagers du rer en
rogne semblait avoir remplacé les
voyageurs égarés et c'est ainsi que j'y
suis allé et j'ai rencontré ces quelques
cavalier solitaire en patagonie est pas
remis parmi tous mes souvenirs du voyage
leur rencontre possède un éclat
particulier
alors lorsqu'on me parle du voyage
une première chose qui sort généralement
c'est qui sort souvent c'est cette hâte
à vouloir quitter la routine vous savez
cette salle routine dont de vaudou nous
voudrions tant que nous voudrions tant
bannir de notre quotidien de nos vies de
notre travail de notre de nos relations
de notre couple alors que lui le voyage
serez paré de toutes les qualités de
toutes les perfections des rencontres
extraordinaires laventure quelque chose
de nouveau tous les jours quelque chose
de tellement différent de de ma petite
vie métro boulot dodo
et bien je peux être en décevoir plus
d'un aujourd'hui mais mais rien n'est
plus routinier qu'une aventure tel que
nous l'avons vécu routine des longues
journées de cheval routine de
l'entretien des chevaux de tous ses
gestes ses mille gestes répétés au
quotidien routine de ses paysages même
en patagonie on pouvait marcher une
journée entière droit devant soi sans
son voir le paysage changé d'un iota
mais cependant loin de mon a figé je
dirais que c'est l'une des raisons
principales qui m'a poussé à partir en
voyage davila écrivait aussi que le
dernier avec beaucoup de clairvoyance
tout ce qui interrompt une routine fait
avorter une possible excellence les
anciens élèves de prépa dans la salle et
les musiciens qui avant de jouer leurs
compositeurs favoris ont passé des
années à s'entraîner chaque jour savent
tous très bien de quoi je parle tout
cerveau vraiment humain se nourrit de
temps de travail et de discipline
alors bien sûr il ne s'agit pas de nier
l'infini misère de notre de nos
mauvaises habitudes et nos petites
routines malsaine de notre quotidien
mais l'enjeu était tout simplement non
pas de les remplacer par un illusoire
voyage sorte de feu d'artifice permanent
l'enjeu était de tâches et d'installer
d'autres routine qui c'est y avait plus
de sens un dernier mot sur cela
rainer maria rilke un poète autrichien
mort au début du 20e siècle écrivent
bien le jeu alain jouera l'un de ces de
ses amis dans ses lettres il disait si
votre quotidien vous paraît pauvre ne
l'accusé pas accuser vous même de ne pas
être assez poète pour appeler à vous ses
richesses mais alors si ce voyage est
cette chose à la fois routinière et
catastrophique si plein si monotone dans
ces deuils dans ses misères dans ses
souffrances et dans ces dangers avant
mieux raison de partir beaucoup diront
que cela ne valait pas la peine de
prendre tant de risques pour si peu et
qu'au fond tout ce que nous avons réussi
tu fais affaire s'est martyrisé quelques
chevaux qui n'avait rien demandé il ya
là un grand mystère quelque chose qui
nous dépasse infiniment et qui à la fois
nous touche au plus profond de nous
mêmes gillot dans un livre superbe que
ma vie demeure que ma joie demeure
écrivaient les hommes
ça n'a jamais été fait pour engraisser
ça a été fait a été fait pour maigrir
sur les chemins traversés des arbres et
les arbres sans jamais voir les mêmes
sans aller dans sa curiosité connaître
ces seul à connaître alors connaître
quoi et bien connaître ce qui importe la
vie et les choses possède une beauté que
le cours quotidiens ne nous dévoile pas
mais qui se révèle à nous lorsque nous
parvenons à un certain degré d'attention
et c'est pour cela que nous avons pris
des risques
grandiose sur les paysages et
passionnante et la découverte du monde
de lier des hommes et de leur diversité
mais seuls l'incommensurable nous sommes
de notre misère quotidienne
seule la commun sur à bhl nous sauve de
l'insignifiance absolue une main tendue
dans la nuit la saveur d'une gorgée
d'eau bue au creux de la main ou la
lumière de certains regards autrement
dit avoir eu faim et soif
avoir avoir souffert mille vexations
avoir souffert de l'indifférence des
hommes et de l'incertitude à la tombée
du jour avoir risqué sa vie mais
connaître la valeur d'une sourire de ses
coéquipiers et d'un peu de chaleur au
coin du feu
un soir de tempête je ne peux pas
terminer sans vous parler de pomper un
général romain dont horace raconte à un
épisode rentrer dans l'histoire
alors qu'il s'apprêtait à prendre le
large avec sa flotte
malgré la tempête il vit ces sommes
terrorisés des perspectives d'une telle
aventure
ces hommes refusaient de prendre le
large alors pomper celui ça sur un
bateau se tourna vers vers son armée est
dit d'une voix de manière à être entendu
de tous naviguer est nécessaire vivre ne
l'est pas je crois je crois que par delà
les siècles il nous adresser ce message
laventure nous est vital elle nous est
plus précieuse que la vie et c'est en
cela que
nous touchons au plus profond de notre
humanité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]